hello there can you believe it's already
week five into the new fortnight season
and the map changes and tiny story
updates keep on coming this week the
bromance got a new member and we'll talk
about that soon so sit your butt down
for eight minutes and slapping code
adamaru to keep this series going
chapter three season three week five
let's do this
so indiana jones finally arrived in
fortnite today and with him came a new
poi based on his tomb raiding pastime
shuffled shrines is a hotspot for
unlocking his outfit and comes with one
of the best movie easter eggs i've ever
seen in a video game by searching for
all four relics and using them as a code
a secret door unlocks it's filled with
traps and should you make it to the
other side we need to do the old
switcheroo straight out of the movies
collecting the gold macguffin and
leaving behind a bag of sand the
brilliance really happens immediately
after that the temple begins to crumble
and you must escape and there so happens
to be a giant boulder rolling after you
such an amazing moment especially for
old people like me the devs definitely
knew their stuff when it came to indiana
jones and gave us a great nod to the
iconic series hey remember when epic
teased his coming this chapter with a
refrigerator in the desert
[Music]
okay on to the really big stuff now and
the story of bill and ted and their new
partner in crime the trespasser we need
to name him before we get to the big
news we need a little recap it's story
time the trio were first found this
season hiding out in a cave behind a
seemingly indestructible wall of rock
after a few days we all worked together
to remove the wall between them and us
and set the bromance free on the island
they've been wandering around the island
for weeks now and so far i've seen them
in 16 different places doing different
things a massive thank you to my discord
family for helping me get this footage
here's everything they've done before
the update today upon leaving the cave
the most common place to find the trio
is driving around the island full-on
cruising listening to the radio they'd
regularly stop and either check out the
locations enjoy a brew and something to
eat or more often than not stop for a
toilet break as the ghost henchman has
bladder issues the next most common spot
to find the bromance is down at condo
canyon staying at the hotel it's
possible to find them in the gym
training keeping fit and when they
aren't doing that they'll be enjoying a
pool party the shadow henchmen grilling
burgers for the boys as the trespasser
learned to swim his former leader the
cube queen never really understood how
to swim
[Music]
it's possible to find the lads chilling
out by a campfire near synapse station
as ghost plays a tune be sure to light
the campfire for them if you run past on
sunny days they'll be sunbathing on the
far right of the island once again
listening to the music ghost offers this
chap is musically talented occasionally
the trio will do something really worth
watching for example they can be found
on the mountaintop near paradigm looking
out over the water i found them in
battle labs but if this was a real game
they'd be looking at the strange
floating orb on the island nearby this
dot has been here for chapters at some
point it must be explained i know some
people believe that is the cube queen
out there but that dot is too far in the
distance to really know the bromance on
very very rare occasions will appear at
the hot watch near the zero point bill
and ted aren't looking at anything in
particular yet the trespasser is looking
towards the zero point confused that orb
is the center of all reality so if you
were a tourist you'd definitely visit
this spot there's still seven more
places to find the boys they can be
spotted taking in a movie at rocky reels
yet no movie actually plays we legit sat
here and waited hoping it was going to
be something like the wreck-it ralph
crossover remember that another pastime
is football or soccer if you prefer over
in tilted towers it looks like the
trespasser is being taught lots of human
traits and hobbies and interests and my
guy is already cracked at footy if you
land at sleepy sound you can find the
bromance seeing a sea shanty by the
lighthouse it's law you must join in and
i lowkey forgot how good that emote
sounds with a full crew
they can be spotted relaxing in kony and
if you're lucky enough they can be found
flying kites on the beach in the
southwest these guys really do get
around they're seeing everything the
island has to offer i mean the shadow
henchmen can be found putting on a
concert at the rave cave being supported
by the rest of the gang check out the
moves of the trespasser my discord firm
and i decided to fill the dance floor a
little and finally there is one that
matters more than all the rest the trio
can stumble across the io trooper
sitting all alone in the old scout
building in the north what's interesting
about this is well it's threefold first
the trespasser isn't bothered at all or
maybe he's a little upset to not be the
center of attention for five minutes he
may be in denial with that rubik's cube
secondly the ghost henchman is excited
to see another npc and points him out
and finally the shadow henchman is
deciding what to do next he tosses a
coin to make that decision and then we
had to wait will they ever make contact
with him we now know exactly what they
did the io guard joined the bro band the
bromance now has four members all the
factions that were in the game are now
in this new super group ghost shadow io
and of course the last reality all we
need now is one of the sevens guards to
join this crew it appears that all the
locations the trio visited last week can
now be visited as a foursome down by the
barbecuing condo the trespasser even
states he's deleting eliminate lupus
protocol and the new protect new friends
behavior is engaged how beautiful is
that so i do think it's time we
officially name these guys this is your
last chance in the comments below to
throw in a name the most upvoted and
reposted will become the new busy mates
of bill and ted or ted and bill i still
don't know which way round they are and
it turns out the lads can go on single
dates as well going off in twos around
the island how very modern and
cosmopolitan of them hit me up on
twitter if you see them on their travels
please i'm adam grenade over on twitter
the next storyline it's over to the rock
family from chapter one this season
they've been simply chilling out on the
beach for five weeks straight dad still
lays waiting for the dog to bring him
slurp barrels and mum continues to read
hang on wait a minute she's read a whole
stack of books since last time
coincidentally the book she read last
week was officially one of midases this
girl is really getting to know fortnite
law and from all those books she's read
she's gone back to cipher's playbook i'm
kind of hoping she slowly cranks 90s and
builds a whole new poi for us in the
next few weeks and the final member of
the rock family kid rock he continues to
build a sand castle yet this week what
is he doing is that a windbreak maybe a
flood defense any ideas what this kid is
up to and have you visited the peely
crash site today it's finally happening
after months of waiting the rebuild of
truckasaurus is imminent he now has his
torso and feet attached i know it's not
much but in the next two updates this
could be complete i'm hoping the paint
job will be peely themed to celebrate
everything that legend has done for us
last week we did have an update let's be
sure to record it now the butter barn
sapling sprouted into another reality
mess this time bringing three locations
coral castle colossal coliseum and neo
tilted to this location most of them had
really cool butter barn references
especially the coliseum my guy has a
perfectly carved stone totem of his head
this is because the romans loved them
some man cake true story so that's the
update this week did i miss anything
please let me know here are some legends
who used code adamaru then sent me a
screenshot in my twitter dms thank you
very much it really helps i'm adam
you're awesome i'll see you next time
[Music]